[Musique]
viens nous sommes sur la nouvelle route
départementale 128 qui vient d'ouvrir au
public et qui permet de désenclaver une
partie du quartier de l'école
polytechnique dont le cadre de l'appel à
projet ecocité ville de demain qui est
porté par l'état et la caisse des dépôts
le ps est engagé dans une action
innovante pour les liaisons douces
[Musique]
il s'agit de mettre en oeuvre une piste
le fluorescents luminescentes qui permet
d'offrir aux usagers un nouveau mode de
transport sans éclairage artificiel
comme nous avons l'habitude de le voir
long de ce genre de piste l'objectif est
de se passer complètement de lumière
artificielle dans une zone très
naturelle du quartier l'école
polytechnique avec de force d'enjeux
environnementaux pour permettre à la
fois de répondre aux attentes des
usagers piétons et cycles mais également
de permettre le développement de la
biodiversité souhaité sur le
l'écoterritoire paris saclay
l'innovation est double et ce à deux
titres
premièrement nous avons mises en oeuvre
cette innovation avec l'aide de deux
entreprises eiffage route et colas qui
ont accepté de tester sur le territoire
paris saclay leurs produits qui
n'étaient pas encore commercialisé la
deuxième l'innovation revient tout
simplement aux procédés de fabrication
de cette piste dans un premier temps
nous réalisons en enrobé tout à fait
traditionnelle puis dans un deuxième
temps nous venons semer des cailloux
fluorescents comme peut le faire un
agriculteur dans son champ puis dans une
troisième étape
nous venons compact et ses cailloux pour
venir en chasser les granulats dans leur
bain aux résultats nous obtenons une
nous voie partagée pour les cycles et
les piétons en répondant aux usages
attendus tout en permettant bien
évidemment de permettre à la faune à la
flore de continuer à se développer de
manière sereine